six a heads up this morning if you have
a teenager in your family
february is teen dating violence
prevention and awareness month
it is an issue that is unfortunately
getting worse here in southern nevada
bianca holman is live this morning with
resources for parents and teenagers
bianca
you know it may be a surprise but kids
as young as 11 years old can experience
relationship abuse and as far as cyber
abuse
on your phone or on the computer that
can be just as powerful as being with
the person
physically now all month long there's an
effort to educate and do outreach around
teen dating violence especially
how to prevent it it's an issue that
impacts about 25 percent of teens and
when it comes to violence most people
think physical abuse
however abuse can be emotional name
calling or the undermining of someone's
confidence or
even isolation extreme jealousy is also
a major red flag
if you think your teen is in danger ask
them about it
saying well don't ever see that person
again
not a good strategy um you need to
identify that there may be a problem and
if there is one that you're there for
them
or there are other folks in the
community that are there for them
so that they feel like you support them
and that if they need you that they can
come to you
of course having that conversation or
experiencing it is
very very hard it's not easy but there
are two virtual forums coming up the
first is for parents and teachers anyone
who works with a teen
that's this thursday at 5 30 p.m it's
virtual and the second
is next tuesday and that's just for
teens they'll be able to hear from a
teen victim
who survived a very abusive relationship
and that is
next tuesday at 3 p.m we have the
details on our website
at 8newsnow.com reporting bianca holman
8 news now